listen to the voice of the Eternal as he
speaks with men as he studies and
meditates upon the themes into which the
Angels desire to look he may have their
companionship he may follow the steps of
the Heavenly teacher and listen to his
words as when he taught on mountain and
plain and sea he may dwell in this world
in the atmosphere of Heaven imparting to
Earth's Sorrowing and tempted ones
thoughts of hope and longings for
Holiness himself coming closer and
closer into fellowship with the Unseen
like him of all who walk with God
drawing nearer and nearer the threshold
of the Eternal World until the portal
shall open and he shall enter there he
will find himself no stranger the voices
that will greet him are the voices of
the Holy ones voices who unseen were on
Earth his
companions voices that he he learned to
distinguish and to love he who through
the word of God has lived in fellowship
with heaven will find himself at home in
Heaven's
companionship education page
127 paragraph 1 God is good all the time
and all the
time thank you very much for enduring
unto the very very bitter end
which is this evening I also welcome
those of you online and our pastor has a
couple questions to ask two three
questions pastoru would you please come
and put the questions let us try to
answer with Biblical
accuracy okay question number one MH
every single time when you pray you end
up saying two times amen and am amen
what's the meaning of that oh it's uh
when God called
Abraham in Genesis 22 he said Abraham
Abraham when he called Moses in Exodus 3
he said Moses Moses when he call Samuel
in 1st Samuel 1 he said Samuel Samuel
now this was Christ in the Old Testament
in the New Testament when he called
Martha he said Martha Martha when he
spoke to Peter he said Simon Simon when
he spoke to um over Jerusalem he said oh
Jerusalem Jerusalem and of course in the
Book of John we have verily verily and
so it's just a matter of confirmation
amen and amen when God gave two dreams
to
Pharaoh in Genesis
4132 I believe it is Joseph explained to
Pharaoh that the dreams were doubled as
evidence that they were confirmed by God
and so I I just say amen and amen thank
you it yes question number
two oh sorry we should pray first US
father as I answer questions give me
wisdom I pray please in Jesus name amen
sorry about
that yes Pastor you said just one amen
this time oh yes
yeah I have S question number
two what is the secret you can quote
most of the Bible by heart and not just
going from Genesis to Revelation in a
word but going there and there and there
it's it's and you are faster than my uh
my uh online Bible in my my cell phone
what's the SEC how can we do that is it
too late for no it's not too late at all
it's a good
question when I was a little boy in the
70 Adventist Church we had something
called morning watch
you had to learn a Bible verse every
day I mean those days are gone but way
back then you had to learn a verse every
day and on Sabbath afternoon in the
young people's service which we call MV
you know how far back that was you had
to recite them everyone had to recite
them plus the memory verse for the
Sabbath school
lesson it this was the environment in
which I grew all the young people did it
but it happened to stay with me also
there was a an Eld eler in my church
called elder pain he died decades ago he
would preach without looking at the
Bible and I was a little boy watching
him and I was just
fascinated and I said to myself I would
love to do
that are and uh
but
I value the Bible very
highly
value will allow you to take extra steps
if you're walking down the street and
you see a penny in the gutter you keep
walking if you see a $100 bill you'll
stop and step down in the gutter and
pick it up because of its value are you
following me and so I value the word of
God very very highly also I just love to
do it as a child I love memorizing poems
and reciting
them but as I got older I realized that
um
the Lord had given me a little gift to
memorize little yes yes little
little and so I have done it over the
years I memorize whether I have to
preach or not I just memorize just to
have it in my head I fly a lot I'm
flying from let's say New York to
Nairobi that's about 9 hours what am I
going to
do pray nap recite Bible
verses um I have it in my hand head all
during the day I'm driving whatever I'm
doing L white says in M character and
personality Volume 2 page 601 paragraph
4 that which at first seems Difficult by
constant repetition grows
easy professional athletes are as good
as they are because they practice all
the time what I'm saying to you is this
if you make an effort to memorize Bible
verses the more you try the more skilled
you'll become we call that practice
makes perfect now as seven the
Adventists we're known for the fourth
Commandment what's the very first word
in the fourth Commandment remember now
that's a command to use your
memory am I speaking the truth to
remember you must use your memory we are
commanded to use our remember
remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy um and so I
I have been convicted by God long time
ago that I ought to preach the way I
preach uh you know from the
head and it's just a personal conviction
it's not something I preach to people
just a personal conviction but the
simple I give you four things I
recommend one you must have the
desire a lot of people admire it they
don't want to imitate it you understand
what I'm saying they admire they don't
want to
copy have a desire
two you must be determined because there
will be some passages that are very very
strange and the words are strange and
the names are strange and you have to
keep at it keep at it if you do it'll
come three you have I said desire I said
discipline you have to
be to seek Divine
help ask God to help you because that's
his word you're dealing with and he will
help you you know Jesus said the spirit
will bring bring back to your mind what
I've said to you so the Holy Ghost
brings back to the mind he strengthens
the mind and so you must have this
desire you must have this determination
this discipline you must seek Divine
help and you must have
determination in other words I will
spend one month memorizing John
11:35 which says
what Jesus wept the two words if it
Takes Me 3 months I am staying with it
until I memorize Jesus
wept that's the termination never give
up never give up Die
Trying it's not
complex over and over and
over when I'm coming driving with my
friends brother Jeffrey sister Anna I'm
on my phone going over
verses and I'm leaving if we're not
talking I'm looking at vers
vers when I go to bed while I'm lying
there I'm going over verses in the night
you're lying there it's dark you go over
verses that has two benefits it keeps it
in my head but you you must remember the
devil attacks your mind at night cable
TV huh cable TV cable okay okay he
attacks your mind at night your only
protection is this really is not the
encyclopedic branica the only protection
is this the Bible says says in Matthew
8:16 and when the even was come they
brought unto him many that were
possessed with devils and he cast out
the spirits with his
word this is our defense against the
devil not only this but the Bible is a
detergent it really is if you take time
to study the
Bible your thinking will
change amen M if try for three weeks a
consistent three weeks of Bible study
once in the morning once in the evening
do it seriously your thinking will
change your secular desires will become
weaker your spiritual desires and urges
will get stronger
guaranteed that's why Jesus told the
disciples in John 15:3 now you clean
through the word which I have spoken
unto you Psalm 119 verse 9 wherewith all
shall a young man cleanse his ways by
taking he thereto according to thy will
you cannot be a Christian if you have no
time for God's word you can be a church
member not a Christian because the power
of a Christian is prayer and the word of
God and so I recommend that you try my
recommendation is the King James version
because it disciplines the mind so much
because a few words are strange but
whatever version you
wants only a few words strange just a
few words yes just a few words what's so
strange about thee and thou you know
nothing really you know I I talk to
young people and they study German they
study Chinese they study Japanese but
they can't read the King James version
and I just don't understand that I just
don't I just don't anyway that's the
secret Pastor consistency determination
discipline and seek Divine help and as
you learn a verse say it over and over
and over so that it comes to you the way
your name comes to you without much
thinking you know there's something
called muscle memory you do something
often enough you do it without thinking
we must have the word of God so we have
mental muscle memory the word comes just
when you need it all right enough of
that what's the next question uh two
more questions um that was one more okay
uh I just got one in the last second so
I have to go right no problem um the
Bible said remember the Sabbath day and
keep it holy however there are several
other
uh days in in the Old Testament call
sabbaths they are those Jewish
festivals um six of them three in the
spring and three in the fall and they
added another one during the uh the
period of between the Old Testament and
New Testament one um and it looks like
uh some Christians are keeping the 7even
day Sabbath but also they're trying to
keep those Old Testament sabbaths
festivals is this something that we
should um continue to do or
not the sacrificial system which
includes
uh uh ritual days called sabbaths which
can fall on any day of the week by the
way the all of that pointed to Christ
who had to come and die for instance of
The Seven Feast the number one the first
one was
what Passover go to 1 Corinthians 5
let's read verse 7
1 Corinthians 5:7 let's look at Passover
which is symbolizes the sacrifice the
death of Christ on Calvary that's what
Passover symbolizes let's go to 1
Corinthians 5 let's read verse
7 do you have that read with me Purge
out therefore what the old leaven that
he may be a new lamp as he are unle
finish that verse for even Christ Our
Passover is sacrificed for us the
Passover pointed to Christ when he died
that was it not just a Passover it
simply represents all the other sacrif
every sacrifice in the Old Testament
pointed to Jesus Christ and when he died
it fulfilled everything now let's go to
uh Matthew 27 let's read from verse
50 Matthew 27 reading from verse 50 and
we read that this morning to Sabbath
school when Brother Carlos was
teaching you have Matthew 27 reading
from verse
50 Jesus when he had cried again with a
loud voice did what he up The Ghost and
behold the veil of the temple was rent
in twn from top to the bottom and the
Earth did shake and the Rocks rain when
Jesus died as soon as Jesus died an
invisible hand tore the
veil now a high priest could not tear
his garments that was Blasphemous
Behavior he was not allowed to tear his
garments during the trial of Jesus the
high priest tore His Garment you see
you're not allowed to tear your garment
but when that veil was torn it
symbolized the end of the sacrificial
system not just one the end of the
system because the entire system pointed
to Jesus
Christ in desar VES page 308 paragraph 3
elwi writes the S this the system of
types that pointed to Christ as the Lamb
of God was to be abolished at his death
when he died that system ended in signs
of the times uh 1914 December 22
paragraph 8 El writes but at the
crucifixion type meant antitype and the
typical system
ceased we are no longer required to keep
the ceremonial feast and the ceremonial
sabbaths the Bible makes a
differentiation between the two let's go
quickly to Leviticus chapter 23 let me
show you what I mean by the Bible making
a differentiation between typical
sabbaths and the Sabbath of creation
which is not
typical you have Leviticus 23 yes we
read from verse one let me pray again
father as I continue answering this
question give me simple language I pray
in Jesus name amen read with me and the
Lord spake unto Moses saying what speak
unto the children of Israel and say unto
them concerning the Feast of the Lord
which he shall Proclaim to be holy
convocations even these are my feast all
right these where are these now in verse
three read with me six days shall work
be done but the seventh day is is the
Sabbath of rest a holy convocation he
shall do no work therein it is the
Sabbath of the Lord in all your
dwellings Now read verse
four these are the feasts of the Lord
even which he shall Proclaim when in
this Seasons now what Moses does he sets
the Sabbath
aside are you following me the next
verse says now these are the feasts and
verse 5 begins in the 10th day of the
fifth month at evening is the Lord's
what Passover next verse and on the 15th
day of the same month is the Feast of 11
bread unto the Lord seven days he must
eat 11 bread the Sabbath is set aside it
is not a ceremonial feast day then we
have the first of the seven beginning at
verse 5 which is Passover ending with
Feast of Tabernacles right down to the
end of that chapter within verse five to
the last verse of that we have
ceremonial sabbaths
for instance let's read verse 6 are you
there read with me what does that say
and in the 15th day of the same month is
the Feast of unleavened bread come
on unto the Lord seven days you must eat
unleavened bread read verse
7 first day shall be a now what's a holy
convocation is a kind of Sabbath
convocation means coming together you
see holy convocation but notice verse
six in the 15th day of the same month
now the 15th day can fall
when any day of the week so the 15th day
for on a Wednesday it was treated as a
holy convocation that's what you call a
ritual Sabbath The Creation Sabbath only
fell Come on talk to me on the seventh
day all the other ritual days can fall
any day of the week
the Sabbath of creation only fell on the
seventh day that's why it is set apart
in verse three before the other feasts
are me or the feasts are mentioned from
verse 5 all the way down to the end of
that chapter we are not required now let
me show you why people who say keep the
feast are not being forthright let's
read verse 7 again of Leviticus 23 what
is that b what is that verse
saying on the first day shall be a holy
convocation keep reading he shall do
no Sur therein but you shall
offer unto the yes yeah yeah offer an
offering May by fire to the Lord you got
to kill an
animal if you tell them you're keeping a
feast today you have a lot of animals to
kill are you with me you must include
all the details of the
feast Christ died once we can't have him
dying again in ceremonial animals are
you f me he died once you and I are not
now we're required to understand what
the feasts mean we should study them
because they have lessons for us they
take us from Calvary to the kingdom of
God in the new world but observe them no
study them
yes mhm any other question Pastor yes
the last
one uh it's a long uh question but uh
the the bottom line here is
this um I'm trying hard focus on the
obedience to God's law but even with
those scriptures here MH and others
following all the God's Commandments
even with the Scriptures it is not easy
mhm question are there other scriptures
or anything else you could suggest to
help fortify our Consciousness and
obeying all the Commandments including
Matthew
539 and Matthew 5:44 mhm how is read
read that question is there any water
are there
any what I understood from this is are
there other scriptures or anything else
you could suggest to help us fortify our
Consciousness in obeying all the
Commandments including Matthew 5:39
Matthew 5:44 all right as you as you
mentioned obedience is is in is not in
our nature yes that's true that's true
obeying the ten command is not uh you
know okay what else like the the Young
Ruler oh I kept them since I was young
what else no it's not easy and the
question I think is aiming at how can we
be helped to keep them okay go to Romans
chapter
8 Romans chapter
it's 6:30 already do you have Romans 8
let's read vers 7 and 8 are you there
read with me because the carnal mind is
enmity against God for it is not subject
to the law of God neither indeed can be
what the verse is saying it is
impossible for an unconverted person to
keep the law of God there is no resource
you can give to an unconverted person to
keep the law of God not just the letter
but the spirit it's
impossible the carnal mind is enmity
against God for it is not subject to the
law of God neither indeed can be now the
solution to that problem let's go to
Ezekiel chapter
36 Ezekiel
36 and here's what we must ask God to do
then we'll find obedience is a joy
Ezekiel 36 read with me verse 26 and
27 very important verses these two
verses have you found them read with me
a new heart also will I give you stop
look at those words again read them for
me I will give
you then what should you
do ask him what did David pray and say
create in me a clean heart oh God and
renew a right Spirit within me a clean
heart is one in which the law of God
abides because there's nothing unclean
in God's law it's all
righteousness a new heart also will I
give you keep reading Ezekiel 36:26 and
a new spirit will I put within you keep
reading and I will take away the Stony
heart out of your flesh and I will give
you a heart of Flesh God says I will
give you something and take away
something I'll take away that Heart of
Stone that does not
obey I'll give you a soft heart that
obeys Now read verse 27 it's very
powerful read for me what does that say
and I
will stop you notice how many times you
see the word
I let's go back to 26 let's look for the
word I let's read
again uh-huh God does it keep
reading I put within you God does it mhm
I will take
away I will give a heart of flesh keep
going verse 27 and I will put my keep
going now the word I isn't there but we
can understand it to be I will cause you
to do
what Tes and ye
shall and what do you understand by I
will cause you to walk in my statues
what do you understand what do you
understand by walk in my statues give me
one word obey what does God say I will
cause you to obey the power to obey is
God in you are you listening to me this
is this is very serious thanks for the
question whoever sent it it is God in us
that empowers us and enables us to obey
why because the law of God is a divine
Divine
Law are you following me no human being
can keep a Divine
Law something has to change either the
law has to be lowered or the person has
to be lifted which one does God do he
lifts if you put helium in a balloon
what happens to the
balloon God put some kind of divine
helium in us and it lift are you with
me I will cause you to walk in my
statutes the power to obey is the
presence of the righteousness of Christ
in us so when you say what can we done
we ask God to do what he has promised to
do I will take away that disobedient
heart I will give you a heart of Flesh
ask him to do that in addition to that
keep staring at calvary's C and remember
why that man died so
painfully because of sin the violation
of God's law and he died for you as an
individual so the power to
obey ask
God as early as go to Genesis 3:15 see
God in action as early as Genesis 3:15
here's what God says he'll
do by the way that was Christ speaking
in Genesis
3 are you there what
chapter what verse read with me and I
will put enmity between thee and the
woman between thy seed and her seed stop
what the word enmity
means hatred hostility M God said I will
put
it now if God puts hostility enmity in
me or you or the church for the devil he
puts enmity in us for
sin are you following me he puts enmity
in us for sin he said I'll do that
before Adam and Eve left the garden
it's no different from I will put a new
spirit within you I will take away the
Stony heart I will give you a heart of
Flesh I will put enmity now you have
enmity in Genesis 3:15 go to Romans 8:7
again let's see the word enmity
again Romans
8:7 are you there I'm sure you know it
because the carnal mind is enmity
against God and and so we have we're
born in a condition that hates God's law
God says only I can change that
condition I will give you a heart that
loves my
law that's why he says this is the
Covenant that I will make with the house
of Israel after those days say the Lord
I will put my law in the inward parts
and write it in their heart Jeremiah
31:33 Hebrews 8:10 Hebrews 10:16 I will
do it because you cannot do it not only
can you not do it you don't want to do
it
go to Romans
3 Romans chapter
3 let's read from verse 10 as we
continue answering this very very good
question do you have Romans 3:1 read
with me what does that saying as it is
written there is none righteous no not
one stop if you're not righteous what
are you if no one is righteous everybody
is MH everybody's sinful there is none
righteous know not one keep reading
there's none that understandeth there's
none that seeketh after God now listen
carefully to the word of
God we see it back in the Garden of Eden
again when God came looking for Adam and
Eve what were they doing they were
hiding they were running from
God that's the carnal nature there's
none that seeketh after God so Jesus
told uh zakus the son of man is come to
seek because you won't seek
him so we have a God who chases you he
seeks you when you allow him to catch
you did you get my words when you allow
him to catch you by stop running he
changes this and then obedience becomes
your great
joy the power to obey is the presence of
the righteousness of Christ and ask him
to do it change this we ask God for all
kinds of things he might not do Lord
give me money my yes or no give me a
husband yes or no I want a child yes or
no I want promotion on the job yes or no
give me a new car yes or no change my
heart yes
am make me generous
yes take away my short temper
yes help me to keep the Sabbath
yes help me to forgive that sister who
wronged me had you in World War II
yes mhm
yes God doesn't hesitate when you say
give me spiritual help amen the power to
obey is to ask God to do what he has
promised to do I will change this and
this amen so that it will be said of you
as it was said of Christ in Hebrews 1:9
thou Hast love righteousness and hated
iniquity let me tell you the things we
love we pursue the things we hate we
avoid we can come to the place where we
absolutely hate sin and the man or the
woman who hates sin is a man or a woman
who loves the law of God can you say
Amen ask God to do what he has promised
to
do salvation is not what you do isn't
what you do it's what God does with your
cooperation listen to Genesis 12 from
verse one let's go there quickly 20
to7 you may consider all of this my
presentation Genesis 12 let's read from
verse
one and God bless you for coming
tonight I forgot to ask is there anyone
present tonight for the very first time
on the last night first time last night
all right Genesis 12 reading from verse
one let me pray father continue to give
me the right words I pray in Jesus name
amen now the Lord has said unto Abram
get thee out of thy country and from thy
Kindred and from thy Father's House unto
a land that I will show thee keep
reading verse two and I will make of the
great nation and I will bless thy name
bless thee and make thy name great you
can put I will make thy name great and I
will bless them that curse thee and
bless them that bless thee and curse him
that curse Thee I will do all these
things all God asked Abraham to do is
obey leave all the rest to me that's the
gospel amen obey and leave all the rest
to to me leave your enemies to me leave
the government to me leave whomever to
me leave them to me just obey leave the
rest to
me
H we try to do God's work we end up in
trouble let him do
his you do yours which is trust and Obey
and God will do everything else let's go
down to Genesis chapter 1 let's go to
Genesis 1 and make a few closing remarks
and then we're done
Genesis 1 we read from verse
one you know it very well the Bible says
in the beginning God created the Heaven
and the Earth question for you how did
God do
that by this MH I can't explain how God
spoke and the light came I can't explain
it all I know is God's word has
tremendous power amen now since the the
word created the word has to be
divine let me say it differently the
life of God is in the word how it occurs
I don't know nor do I know how my lungs
work exactly I don't know but I'm glad
they work are you following me am in the
beginning God created the Heaven and the
Earth how by his word Psalm 33:6 by the
word of the Lord with the heavens made
and all the host of them by the breath
of his mouth verse 9 for he spake and it
was done he commanded it stood
fast when Christ stood at the tomb of
Lazarus in John 11 he said Lazarus come
forth and a dead man came out of a
tomb all Christ did was speak there is a
mysterious power in the word of God Amen
are you following me yes Matthew 8:16
the Bible says and when the even was
come they brought unto him many that
were possessed with devils and he cast
out the spirits with his word amen
there's something about the word that
terrifies the devil
amen he cast out the
spirits with his word your enemy and
mine is not your boss or your neighbor
or the person who owes you money that
you loan you should not have
loaned your enemy is the devil with whom
we cooperate the power to overcome him
is this amen so we've seen the word of
God is the power that
creates the word of God is the power
that repels the devil the word of God is
the power that maintains creation
Hebrews 1:3 who being the brightness of
his glory and the express image of his
person and upholding All Things by the
word of his power amen all things
macroscopic on the large scale all
things microscopic on the invisible
scale by the word of God
Amen go to Psalm
119 we read verse 89 to
91 Psalm
119 89 to 91 we're looking at God's
word you have Psalm
119 what verses did I say 89 to 91 read
with me what does that say forever oh
Lord Thy word is settled in heaven look
at verse 90 thy faithfulness is unto all
generations thou Hast established the
Earth and it abideth now read carefully
verse 91 they continue this day
according to thine ordinances stop okay
all of thy
servants now let me tell you a little
about Psalm 119 I think I might have
told you the first week it's divided
into 228 SE 22 sections eight verses
each and in a certain way each section
is self-contained it has its own message
the next it have their own message but
they all uplift obedience to the laws of
God and the blessings of obeying God
that's why the very first verse says
blessed are the undefiled in the way who
walk in the law of the Lord and the very
last verse says I have wondered like a
lost sheep seek thy servant for I do not
forget thy Commandments begins with obey
ends with obey now verse 89 begins one
of these eight verse
sections 89 says forever O Lord Thy word
is settled where in heaven the next
verse says what thy faithfulness is unto
all all generations thou has established
the Earth and it abideth so we have
heaven in 89 Earth in 90 then in 91 they
say they continue who is
they come on Heaven and Earth yes they
continue or they remain
how read verse they continue this
day according to thy ordinances
ordinances means
laws you the laws that govern space the
laws that govern solids liquids gases
they continue according to thy
ordinances this is the word of
God the word that creates the word
sustains are you with
me now if the word creates the word
sustains as I said there's something
mysteriously powerful about the word of
God who is the first person in the Bible
to die
able that's about 6,000 years
ago if any dead person is dirt now it's
able are you with me 6,000 years listen
to 1 Thessalonians 4:16 you know it very
well for the Lord himself shall descend
from heaven with a shout come on with a
voice of the Archangel and with the
Trump of God and Abel shall rise first M
MH Jesus Christ called Abel righteous in
Matthew 23 Paul calls him righteous in
Hebrews 11
verse4 the right the dead in Christ
shall rise first the righteous Abel is
the first
one now we
know then we which are alive and remain
shall be caught up with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord where in the air
when Christ comes the second time he
doesn't touch the
Earth you need to understand that so if
someone is walking on the earth saying
I'm Jesus you can just walk away
when Christ comes the second time he
does not touch the earth I don't care
what David cores said or Jim Jones or
whom ever called themselves
Jesus so he's up in the air
somewhere we rise to meet him now
imagine
this since Abel died there was a flood
am I right the Earth was torn up there
an Earthquakes we don't know where ab's
dirt
went Jesus stands somewhere in the sky
and speaks and Abel comes back
together amen there's something in the
word of
God now in Luke 7 Jesus healed or raised
the Widow of Na's son remember that
story he touched the coffin or the bear
and said young man I say unto thee
arise listen to these words carefully
there is our VES page 320 paragraph 2 as
the word of God which B the first man
live still gives us life the word bade
means command b a d e all English word
as the word of
God which B the first man live who is
the first
man how was he brought to
life by the word of God by the word of
God don't look baffled by the word of
God as the word of God which B the first
man live still gives life as the words
young man I see until the arise gave
life to the Youth of n so the word awake
arise from the dead is life to the soul
who receives it let's go find arise from
the dead go to Ephesians
5 Ephesians
5 and I want you to concentrate as you
have been
doing you have Ephesians 5 let's read
verse
read nice and Loud wherefore he saith
awake thou that sleepest and arise from
the dead who is he that's God wherefore
he saith awake thou that sleepest and
arise from the dead that's the word of
God now arise from the dead sounds like
what M but be more
specific John
11 Lazarus come
forth are you
following arise from the dead is no
different from Lazarus come forth now as
Lazarus was resurrected
physically by Lazarus come forth any
person who accepts by faith arise from
the dead Ephesians 5:14 will be
resurrected
spiritually because it is the same
person speaking the words let me say it
again arise from the dead in Ephesians
5:14 needs to be spoken to people who
are spiritually
dead if they will receive that word that
statement arise from the dead as verily
as Jesus told the the the paralytic at
Bethesda rise take up thy bed and
walk arise from the dead has the same
power to bring someone from spiritual
death to spiritual life change a life
that seem to human beings
lost arise from the dead but it has to
be
received has to be received you see
because the life is in the word
itself when you receive the word truly
with all your heart and soul and mind
and strength and might and understanding
it works miracles in your
life I am saying all this to say to
you make time for God's
word
please amen tell me if this is
reasonable we live in a world created by
God's word yes or no yes we are part of
a universe created by God's word yes or
no this universe is sustained by the
same
word then how do we fit into that kind
of system living according to God's word
MH to live contrary to God's word is to
go contrary to God's plan for the entire
universe the entire universe runs on
God's
word the power that removes bad habits
is God's word amen the power that
conquers a short Temple is God's word
amen
amen the power that removes stinginess
is God's word amen but not God's word in
a book God's word received into the
heart and the mind it will cleanse
you it is the cleansing agent of
God Christ object lessons page 100
paragraph 1 El white writes if studied
and
obeyed the word of God works in the
heart subduing what does subdue
mean bring under control every Unholy
attribute
everyone the public ones and the secret
ones nobody
knows if studied and obeyed let me tell
you something you cannot sin and pray at
the same
time you cannot sin and exercise Faith
at the same time one has to
stop that's why people don't sin before
the don't pray before they sin Lord help
me to commit fornication nobody prays
that are you following me nobody prays
that you can't do
it if you're on your knees praying you
cannot
sin me you really praying to God Amen in
order to sin you've got to loose the
Bible for a little while sin then come
back to
it that's why we have to hold on to God
moment by moment and we hold on to God
through his word
amen and so I offer to you thus sayth
the
Lord by the word of the Lord were the
heavens made and all the host of them by
the breath of his mouth for he spake and
it was done he commanded it stood fast
and the reputation of God is based on
the fact he always keeps his word we
have this saying you can take it to the
bank you can take God's word to Fort
Knox you don't know what fort nox is
okay I want you to make a commitment
that you will make time for the word of
God listen to me
carefully this is life and
death please live a decent life if you
can but it is not a decent life that
saves you because you do not need the
word of God to live a decent life most
atheists are
decent we need a life empowered by thus
sayth the
Lord
amen Jesus told the disciples in John
15:3 he clean through the word speaking
of the church Paul says of Jesus that he
might sanctify and cleanse it with the
washing of Water by the word
amen Jesus prayed to his father in John
17 he told the father sanctify them
through thy truth Thy word is
truth and Jesus said in verse 19 of the
same chapter and for their sakes I
Sanctified myself how by the word of the
father
amen let me get back to the question the
power to obey is in the word of
God you get power to obey as you
obey are you following me don't wait for
power to keep the Sabbath start keeping
it and you'll feel the
power don't wait for power to obey start
obeying and in that Act of Faith the
power will be released when Jesus healed
the the 10 lepers in Luke
17 he told them go show yourselves to
the priest the Bible says verse 14 as
they were going or as they were
obeying they were
cleansed as they were doing what Jesus
said the proess the pro they were
cleansed power to obey is released in
obedience
amen so when God says in Ezekiel
36:27 I will cause you to walk in my
statutes meaning I'll cause you to obey
if you accept that the power is in that
it's not I read it and I go get the
power it's in the word are you following
me but the word has to be here and here
accepted I understand willing to do it
amen and then you see miracles in your
lives there are people whose lives have
been changed because they read one Bible
verse and there those people who are
changed and sustained because they
remained in the very word that changed
their lives I cannot overestimate the
word of God you know how Jesus forgave
amen he said thy sins are forgiven thee
he spoke
it the Bible says for the word of God is
quick and Powerful sharper than any
two-edged sword piercing even to the
dividing of Thunder have Soul and Spirit
and joint and Marrow and is a discerner
of the thoughts and intents of the heart
those secret motives you and I are not
even aware of the word of God will
expose
them
amen let me make the call now will you
not decide to make time for God's
word first thing in the morning lasting
at night and if you decide to memorize
some verses say them during the
day it will strengthen your mind I'm not
a nurse I'm not a doctor but for me my
my cure for Alzheimer's is memorizing
the
Bible now the Food and Drug
Administration has not evaluated that
statement but that's my medication are
you following me fill my head with
this because when Jesus healed he used
this are you not with me this is what he
used to
heal it only make sense if this is what
he used to heal that's what I want in
this
hard concrete block I call my
head how many of you will say father
help me to make time for your word can I
your hand I want you to mean
stand up with
me I
uh
father thank you for the two weeks of
traveling through your
word thank you de God for the faithful
members who came some came every single
night did not miss one
session if someone came for one session
we're grateful for that
tonight it all ends day God as far as a
seminar is concerned let it not end in
our individual lives regarding the word
father let us live in your word walk in
your word feed on your word de God above
and beyond physical food as job said
have esteemed the words of his mouth
more than my necessary food as Jeremiah
said thy words were found and I did eat
them as Jesus said I have meat to eat
you know not
of God
please help us to love your word because
the man or the woman who loves your word
loves power and loves
you thank you de God for the great honor
you gave me to fellowship with your
people at the hamd church this part of
the world bless
them in all they do bless them de
God give them victory over the
weaknesses wherever they live let that
be a place of light and
safety wherever they go let people be
blessed by their
presence bless Pastor
ofu give that man the wisdom you gave to
Solomon that he may guide your people
all right because the system of guidance
originated with you bless his family put
a double blessing on his
children now
father bless sister Anna and brother
Jeffrey with whom I stayed for two weeks
I want to thank them in a prayer
bless them Father empty the storehouse
of Heaven upon them protect them from
harm and danger give them good health
defend them from the enemies their God
bless their
children if they have relatives out of
the Ark of Safety bring them in I pray
amen Amen Let everyone who entered their
homes be blessed and sense the presence
of your
spirit I personally thank you for their
kindness to me me and I just want him to
understand as I pray in as much as
you've done it unto one of the least of
these my brethren you've done it to me
and father they're listening to the
least of your
servants God bless this family day God
and save brother Jeffrey save sister
Anna when you come do everything in your
power to save them and their families
thank you for all the members who were
so kind to me special word of thanks
with the little boys and little girls
father when you come into your kingdom
save everyone who came to these meetings
I pray from my heart until then Keep Us
Faithful de God in Jesus name I pray let
God's people say amen and amen I love
you if ever I come across your mind all
I want you to say is Lord put your words
in that man's mouth God bless you God
bless you amen the